so your friend from the bar knows where  your sheets are yeah he's crashed her a  few times on the futon so he knows  whether  sheets are a friend  yeah a friend  just a friend yes Mom just a friend  what is going on here who who is this  guy what's happening why is he still  here I don't understand you were acting  so weird and you don't even look Us in  the face you're acting so weird he's my  boyfriend well  your boyfriend yes  I'm  I'm  gay  I'm gay too  I am also gay  I am  why couldn't you tell me that why did  you keep it such a secret what am I some  horrible monster you can't say that to  me you have to just hide it all the time  I didn't know how to tell you I didn't  do high school yeah  talk about it's not just he's a  I think he's a great kid  I think it's great that you guys do you  guys have each other and and uh  we may not look like it but we are  actually kind of hip your mother and I  and uh  we were gonna go to Woodstock you know